have you ever seen the modal Lisa it's
so small I took my daughter to live cuz
she wanted to see it so badly when I
walked up and I saw how small it was
like what da Vinci and right out of
canvas what's the deal and I thought
Mariah would be so disappointed cuz she
was maybe 10 years old and she stood
there and it was quiet she never said a
word and minutes went by and finally she
said I could stand here and look at her
all day long and I realized that if you
have true genius you just don't really
need that large of a canvas if you
really have something to say then
harness the ability to say it in such a
way that the fewer the words the more
powerful